the beginning of everything the Big Bang
the idea that the universe was suddenly
born and is not infinite up to the
middle of the 20th century most
scientists thought of the universe as
infinite and ageless until Einstein's
theory of relativity gave us a better
understanding of gravity and Edwin
Hubble discovered that galaxies are
moving apart from one another in a way
that fits previous predictions in 1964
by accident cosmic background radiation
was discovered a relic of the early
universe which together with other
observational evidence made the Big Bang
the accepted theory in science since
then improved technology like the Hubble
telescope has given us a pretty good
picture of the Big Bang and the
structure of the cosmos recent
observations even seem to suggest that
the expansion of the universe is
accelerating
but how did this Big Bang work how can
something come from nothing let's
explore what we know
[Music]
we can ignore the beginning part for now
first of all the Big Bang was not an
explosion it was all space stretching
everywhere all at once the universe
started very very very small and quickly
expanded to the size of a football the
universe didn't expand into anything
space was just expanding into itself the
universe cannot expand into anything
because the universe has no borders
there is by definition no outside the
universe the universes all there is in
this hot dense environment energy
manifested itself in particles that
existed only for the tiniest glimpses of
time from gluons pairs of quarks were
created which destroyed one another
perhaps after giving off more gluons
these found other short-lived quarks to
interact with forming new quark pairs
and gluons again matter and energy were
not just theoretically equivalent it was
so hot they were practically the same
stuff so we're around this time matter 1
over antimatter today we're left with
almost all matter and nearly no
antimatter at all somehow 1 billion and
one matter particles were formed for
every 1 billion particles of antimatter
instead of one massive ultimate force in
the universe there were now several
refined versions of it acting under
different rules by now the universe has
stretched to a billion kilometres in
diameter which leads to a decrease in
temperature the cycle of quarks being
born and converted back to energy
suddenly stops from now on we work with
what we have quarks begin forming new
particles hadrons like protons and
neutrons there are many many
combinations of quarks that can form all
sorts of hadrons but only very few are
reasonably stable for any length of time
please take a moment to appreciate that
by now only one second has passed since
the beginning of everything
the universe which has grown to 100
billion kilometers is now cold enough to
allow most of the neutrons to decay into
protons and form the first atom hydrogen
imagine the universe at this point has
an extremely hot soup 10 billion degrees
Celsius filled with countless particles
and energy over the next few minutes
things cooled and settled down very fast
atoms formed out of hadrons and
electrons making for a stable and
electrically neutral environment some
call this period the Dark Age because
there were no stars and the hydrogen gas
didn't allow visible light to move
around but what's the meaning of visible
light anyway when there's nothing alive
yet that could have eyes when the
hydrogen gas clumped together after
millions of years and gravity put it
under great pressure stars and galaxies
began to form their radiation dissolved
the stable hydrogen gas into a plasma
that still permeates the universe today
and allows a visible light to pass
finally there was light ok but what
about the part we didn't talk about what
happened right at the beginning this
part can be defined as the Big Bang we
don't know at all what happened here
at this point our tools break down
natural law stopped making sense time
itself becomes wibbly-wobbly to
understand what happened here we need a
theory that unifies Einstein's
relativity and quantum mechanics
something countless scientists are
working on right now but this leaves us
with lots of unanswered questions were
there universes before our own is this
the first and only universe what started
the Big Bang or did it just occur
naturally based on laws we don't
understand yet we don't know and maybe
we never will but what we do know is
that the universe as we know it started
here
and gave birth to particles galaxies
stars the earth and you since we
ourselves are made of dead stars we are
not separate from the universe we are
part of it you could even say that we
are the universe's way of experiencing
itself so let's keep on experiencing it
until there are no more questions to ask
[Music]
you